nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportages long format de
france 24 direction les territoires
palestiniens pour une plongée au coeur
d'un pouvoir qui va si face à une
contestation croissante
mahmoud abbas le successeur de yasser
arafat est aujourd'hui un leader
vieillissant malades qui s'accroche au
pouvoir depuis 16 ans qui vient
d'annuler les prochaines élections
générales et dont le bilan est très
contesté aujourd'hui l'autorité
palestinienne est accusé par les
palestiniens eux-mêmes d'oppression la
mort l'an dernier d'un célèbre activiste
palestinien a achevé de discréditer aux
yeux de beaucoup le pouvoir en place à
ramallah 1 passe en palestine c'est un
document de gwendoline de bono et
laurent van der stockt pour france 24
[Musique]
les deux frères ennemis le palais des
congrès
[Musique]
nizar ben and hate semble savoir qu'il
parle à son public pour la dernière fois
[Musique]
trois jours après cette vidéo cet
activiste politique est assassiné par
les services de sécurité palestiniens
suivi par plus de cent mille personnes
sur les réseaux sociaux nizar ben and
hate dénoncé avec force la corruption
qui gangrène l'autorité palestinienne
format jazeera socquet milliers de
couples sont camille maillot de
profondeur du mal à chalabre abeba club
et art déco la vie
des z'arts bagdad est mort lorsque les
forces de sécurité finissent par le
transférer à l'hôpital
elles viennent de l'interpeller avant de
l'emmener inconscient dans une voiture
[Musique]
ces images issues des caméras de
surveillance ont été versées au dossier
judiciaire
[Musique]
mohamed et hussein les cousins de nizar
ben and at on assisté au meurtre tous
les trois sont endormis dans la maison
familiale lorsque les hommes de l'unité
font irruption dans la nuit
mais nizar dort là son visage fait face
au mur
quand le groupe entre le type avec la
barre de fer se mêla et il se met à le
frapper de toutes ses forces
à ce moment là j'imagine que nizar ne
pensais pas que ce qui se passe était
réelle
d'un coup il s'est réveillé et a dit
tout doucement vraiment doucement
mais qu'est ce qui se passe
quand il a redit qu est ce qui se passe
et tourner sa tête le reste de l'unité
se ruent sur nizar ils encerclent ils
sont au moins neuf ou dix dans le coin
et le frappe comme des sourds
il a commencé à inhaler de plus en plus
difficilement sa respiration était
courte il ne pouvait pas respirer
complètement les coûts n'arrêtait pas
ils l'ont emmené ici
ses mains étaient attachées il le tenait
ils ont commencé à frapper sa tête
contre le mur sans s'arrêter plus de
cinq ou six fois il ne tenait pas debout
ce sont eux qu'il portait
l'autorité palestinienne affirme d'abord
que nizar banet est décédé de mort
naturelle
l'autopsié demandée par la famille elle
indique que 42 coups portés par des
barres de fer ont provoqué la menthe
sérieusement est-ce que ce nizar c'était
ben laden il n'a jamais jeté une pierre
jamais tiré une balle il ne les a jamais
menacé avec une arme rien c'était un
opposant politique
naizain fait de la politique et donc oui
il critique il se bat contre eux avec
des mots ils critiquent leur corruption
il voulait changer ça c'est tout
après l'annoncé de son décès un slogan
inédit va être scandé dans les rues de
ramallah
pour la première fois les palestiniens
cible directement leurs dirigeants les
manifestants marchent vers le palais
présidentiel où résident marco d'abbas
élu en 2005 pour un mandat de quatre ans
le président de l'autorité palestinienne
n'a jamais quitté le pouvoir il vient
d'annuler les premières élections
générales prévues depuis 16 ans la mort
de nizar ben and hate candidats aux
élections a fait l'effet d'un catalyseur
je suis venu pour protester contre
l'autorité palestinienne contre leur
répression et leur oppression on est
descendus dans la rue parce que nizar
ban a été tué
chaque manifestation et réprimer
ce jour là les forces de l'ordre ne sont
pas visibles des membres du fatah le
parti de mahmoud abbas qui verrouille
l'autorité palestinienne prenne pour
cible les manifestants
ils confisquent des téléphones et
intimident physiquement ceux qui lancent
des slogans anti abbas
je parle j'exprime mon opinion c'est mon
opinion
certains manifestants sont emmenés par
des policiers en civil
d'autres sont aspergé de spray au poivre
par les supporters de mahmoud abbas
c'est pas possible c'est quoi ça on
parle on dire un mot et on s'en prend
plein la gueule on se fait frapper parce
qu'on a parlé c'est quoi ces lois tous
dénoncent un régime corrompu
l'autorité palestinienne est le premier
employeur ans et j'en ai eu des milliers
d'emplois publics s'obtiennent par
piston la gestion du budget est opaque
et la population est à bout ça augmente
ça augmente ça fait longtemps qu'ils
nous contrôler prenez les taxes par
exemple il nous prélève des taxes mais
où est-ce qu'elles vont on ne sait pas
ça ne sert à rien parce qu'il ya de la
corruption regardez l'état des routes
les projets ils se les distribuer entre
eux les restaurants c'est eux qui les
possède tout ce qu'il ya dans ce pays
ces tables où va l'argent qu'on reçoit
de l'étranger il utilise cet argent dans
les magasins les restaurants et nous on
est là la bouche ouverte ça suffit on en
a marre il faut trier du changement mais
là on est juste là parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui s'est fait tuer
ce jour-là de palestine se font face
d'un côté les manifestants qui
s'opposent à la corruption et à la
dérive autoritaire de leurs dirigeants
de l'autre les supporters du fatah de
mahmoud abbas qui accusent la foule de
faire le jeu de leur ennemi juré le
hamas parti islamiste au pouvoir à gaza
si le hamas arrive au pouvoir vous en
paierez tous le prix nous aussi on
condamne ce qui est arrivé à nizar nos
si les fils du fatah on veut que justice
soit faite
mais pas comme vous qui insultait
mahmoud abbas vous le traité de traître
et c'est une honte
même si vous le détestez critiqué le
mais l'insulté comme ça c'est une honte
une honte une honte
moi je suis palestinenne rien à [__]
du hamas rihanna fou du fatah c'est quoi
ton problème
c'est quoi ton problème
ils ont tué ni zara est bon demain ça
sera peut-être mon tour ensuite le tour
de quelqu'un d'autre ça peut nous
arriver à tous
une soixantaine de manifestants sont
arrêtés
[Musique]
des professeurs des poètes des
activistes ou encore des étudiants
certains sont poursuivis devant les
tribunaux pour participation à un
rassemblement illégal
l'union européenne principal bailleur de
fonds de l'autorité palestinienne
dénonce cette vague de répression
le pouvoir n'y prêtent que peu
d'attention comme son est vite rendu
compte hanan ashrawi
il y a deux ans cette figure de la
politique palestinienne démissionne du
comité exécutif de l'olp et
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine elle est alors usé par des
instances toujours plus autocratique
elle en témoignent les récentes
critiques de la communauté
internationale n'ont pas eu beaucoup
d'effet sur mahmoud abbas
il y avait beaucoup de pression sur les
dirigeants et particulièrement sur le
président donc il a donné le change
ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a
sélectionné des gens à travers ses
fidèles qui ont invité des responsables
de la société civile
a rencontré le président
ça s'est transformé en exercice de
communication
il n'y avait ni agenda ni objectif ni
engagement
il s'agissait juste d'un rendez-vous
d'une rencontre d'écouté le président et
de rentrer chez soi
mais ensuite qu'est-ce qui est sorti de
cela
qu'on s'est réuni entre membres
d'organisations et on a préparé un
document politique basée sur des
principes à respecter
de transparence de respect de la loi etc
et nous n'avons eu aucune réponse
jamais
beaucoup de gens ont été très déçus
c'est vrai que je pourrai dire que j'ai
démissionné parce que j'ai essayé de
changer les choses de l'intérieur
pendant des années mais personne
n'écoute j'aime
où
[Musique]
le pouvoir se recroqueville sur ses
services de sécurité et la répression
continue à bas bruit
quatre mois après les funérailles de
nizar ben and hate un éloge funèbre est
organisée à ramallah par sa femme
[Musique]
une quinzaine de policiers palestiniens
sont postés à l'entrée de la salle
[Musique]
aux côtés de race and son frère deux des
enfants de nizar ben and hate sont
présents
dans le public nombre de jeunes
palestiniens descendus dans la rue juste
après le meurtre
najlae zeitoun journaliste a été tabassé
par les forces de sécurité pendant les
premiers rassemblements
ils ont volé son téléphone
aujourd'hui les manifestations ont cessé
pas les intimidations de l'appareil
sécuritaire
ils m'ont menacé de poursuites et de
viol ils sont plusieurs à l'avoir fait
les menaces continuent jusqu'à
aujourd'hui quarante jours après la mort
de nizar j'ai été menacé j'étais encore
blessé mon bras était encore bande est
pas tout à fait remis ils m'ont menacé
ils m'ont dit cette fois ci c'est ton
bras qu'on a cassé la prochaine fois
c'est à tête ce qu'on va briser
mon téléphone est toujours entre leurs
mains
il continue les provocations avec mon
téléphone il publie des photos privées
des conversations privées cette fois ci
en plus de cela il ya quelque chose qui
honnêtement m'a vraiment fait peur m'a
fait penser que je n'étais plus du tout
en sécurité
ils ont piraté mon instagram et on fait
des story sous mon nom disons que
j'étais désespéré que je voulais me
suicider
ils étaient plusieurs à me surveiller à
me filmer à l'école des enfants à
l'université sur mon lieu de travail
même encore aujourd'hui ici à
l'intérieur il ya des gens que l'on a
appris à reconnaître qu'ils sont
présents et qui nous financent moment
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tard les dirigeants
de l'autorité palestinienne sont réunis
pour commémorer la mort de seb erekat
figure incontournable de tous les
pourparlers de paix avec israël
au premier rang mohammed shtayyeh le
premier ministre palestinien
il est régulièrement cité comme
potentiel successeur de mahmoud abbas
il écoute une allocution préenregistrés
du président
âgé de 86 ans malade le raïs n'a paraît
presque plus en public
bien plus que le président c'est donc le
premier ministre qui porte la voix de
l'autorité palestinienne
interrogé sur la répression des
manifestations mohammed shtayyeh plaide
l'erreur
nous tenons les gens pour responsable de
ce qui s'est passé à ramallah après les
manifestations
c'est arrivé on ne lit pas
mais comme je les dis il y a des gens
qui ont dépassé les bornes nous
n'autorisons pas et nous nous élevons
contre ça
interrogé sur la mort de nizar ben and
hate le chef du gouvernement plaide
l'erreur une fois de plus
un cas
c'est un seul et unique cas on le
regrette
c'est triste pour la famille
cet homme est mort entre les mains de
nos forces de sécurité
14 officiers des forces de sécurité ont
été arrêtées
ils sont en train d'être jugé la justice
suit son cours ça arrive mais on traite
le dossier dans les règles de la
meilleure manière possible
pour la famille de nizar ben and hate la
ligne de défense de l'autorité
palestinienne est un non sens
son frère hassan affirme que nizar
savait qu'il allait mourir
pour lui les officiers palestinien
responsable du meurtre ont exécuté des
ordres venus d'en haut
au milieu du ramadan il y eu des tirs
contre la maison du niesr cela fait
suite à une campagne de diffamation
contre lui sur les réseaux sociaux tout
ça est arrivé après l'envoi d'une lettre
à l'union européenne pour leur demander
d'arrêter de financer l'autorité
palestinienne et nizar été l'un des
signataires
il postait des photomontage avec la tête
de nizar sur des soldats israéliens
pendant deux jours il y eut des dizaines
et des dizaines d'image comme ça le
troisième jour ils ont ouvert le feu sur
sa maison et ensuite nizar s'est réfugié
chez notre oncle au sud
là on a reçu plusieurs coups de fil
anonyme disant on va tunise art il faut
exécuter nizar ce genre d'appel
via des intermédiaires l'autorité
palestinienne à proposer à la famille un
accord à l'amiable avant la tenue du
procès des meurtriers présumés
une humiliation de plus pour le klan
banan
ils veulent que l'on se taise que l'on
reste silencieux et nous donner le
montant d'argent que l'on souhaite mais
nous sommes très loin de tout ça
ils veulent nous offrir d'autres choses
comme des postes de positions
importantes et prendre en charge les
frais afférents aux enfants de nizar
mais c'est non
nous n'acceptons aucune de leurs offres
nous voulons un procès équitable nous ne
voulons pas d'argent
vous avez tué un homme comment vous
imaginez la suite qu'est ce que vous
attendez de nous
que l'on accepte votre argent et que
l'on n'oublie nisa
mais nous sommes confrontés à une
autorité bornes et autoritaire pas une
autorité qui nous protège
c'est l'autorité des monstres des
monstres qui tue pendant la nuit qui
tabasse pendant la nuit et le jour ils
se présentent comme des mains innocentes
j'ai publié sur les réseaux sociaux
juste une photo de nizar mon supérieur
m'a dit que cet interdit de publier sur
les pages des réseaux sociaux des
messages de deuil en ce qui concerne
nizar garde ton deuil pour toi comment
j'élève mon enfant mon fils je lui dis
ton père hassan est le frère du martyr
nizar et quand il me demandera qui a tué
niesr qu'est ce que je vais lui répondre
l'autorité palestinienne comment je veux
inculquer à mon fils l'amour de la
patrie la loyauté à la patrie alors que
les fils de cette patrie s'entretuent
g
[Musique]
dans la région d'hébron fief de nizar
ben and hate l'autorité palestinienne
est de plus en plus remise en question
à cause de la répression mais surtout à
cause d'un sentiment d'abandon face à la
violence des colons israéliens
[Musique]
je fais ça tous les matins j'ai commencé
à faire ça en 2017 et je continue
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mohammad 17 ans va chercher des enfants
venus du village voisin
escorté par l'armée israélienne il passe
par un chemin qui traverse une colonie
pour rejoindre leur école les
palestiniens adultes n'ont plus le droit
de l'emprunter
c'est le chemin du village de touba qui
a été fermé par les colons car il donne
accès alors que l'oni
le but c'est d'aller à la rencontre des
élèves de touba qui viennent accompagnés
par l'armée israélienne
on les accompagne à l'école pour qu'ils
puissent l'étudier
depuis 2017 j'ai vu beaucoup d'incidents
arrive et des enfants agressés à coups
de pierres certains saignaient de la
tête d'autres ont été menacés tout ça
pour qu'ils arrêtent d'emprunter ce
chemin
à cause de leurs provocations ils
finissent par avoir peur pour leur vie
certains pensent à arrêter l'école et
d'autres le font réellement donc je suis
là pour les encourager parce que nous
vivons sous occupation c'est un fait
nous qu'on ne peut rien faire d'autre
que de l'accepter et de continuer
cela affecte beaucoup les élèves il se
lève très tôt le matin il se prépare il
attend de l'armée et marche sur une
longue distance de leur maison jusqu'au
point où l'armée les rejoint
parfois la remettons retard donc
eux-mêmes arrive en retard à l'école et
après l'école ils attendent encore
longtemps l'armée ils rentrent chez eux
fatigués épuisés ils ont faim ils sont
déprimés et frustré et ça se voit dans
le résultat si l'eau
la violence augmente cette année les
colons israéliens sont devenus vraiment
plus violent on avait des bâtiments là
ils les ont brûlés des racines et les
oliviers et attaquer les moutons je
voudrais que l'autorité palestinienne
nous montre au moins son soutien il
devrait nous défendre et nous soutenir
il devrait être là quand il ya un
incident et venir nous voir
ici la solution à deux états est
désormais perçue comme une chimère
[Musique]
le gouvernement israélien s'accommode de
ses espoirs qui s'amenuisent et de cette
autorité palestinienne qu'ils
contribuent à affaiblir
[Musique]
une erreur stratégique majeure pour ami
ayalon ancien directeur du renseignement
intérieur israélien
de plus en plus de palestiniens voient
mahmoud abbas comme un traître comme un
collaborateur des israéliens
je me souviens quand j'étais le
directeur du shin bet ont coopéré avec
les organisations sécuritaires
palestiniennes
le but c'était de planifier ensemble la
manière de lutter contre le terrorisme
le terrorisme palestinien mais aussi le
terrorisme juif
il me disait à chaque fois nous nous
battons contre nos frères ou les
emprisonnent on les interroge seulement
parce que nous croyons qu'au bout du
chemin on arrivera à l'indépendance
on créera un état palestinien aux côtés
d'israël
au moment où nous n'y croiront plus au
moment où les palestiniens dans la rue
n'y croiront plus le moment où je ne
pourrais plus aller au marché faire mes
courses parce que j'aurais peur des
protestations de la rue à ce moment-là
oublier non
et c'est exactement ce qui se passe on
le voit tous les jours c'est très
dangereux d'être confrontés une société
qui pense qu'elle n'a plus rien à perdre
[Musique]
l'idée d'un état palestinien souverain
s'effondre lentement et avec elle
l'autorité palestinienne miné par la
corruption et les querelles internes
alors certains palestiniens se retourne
contre elle
balata le plus grand camp de réfugiés de
cisjordanie
un kilomètre carré pour 30000 habitants
m
l'autorité palestinienne a presque perdu
tout contrôle de cette zone
cette nuit là le qu'on s'apprête à
retrouver l'un des siens de retour après
17 ans d'incarcération dans une prison
israélienne
[Musique]
pour l'accueillir les miliciens des
factions armées marche vers les limites
du court dès les premiers tirs les
forces de l'autorité palestinienne les
repoussent à l'intérieur de balata
ils évitent soigneusement d'y pénétrer
chacune de leurs incursions peut
dégénérer
dans la foule ahmad
ce soir là il est en civil c'est un
prénom d'emprunt et nous ne montrerons
pas son visage
ils reviennent des gens sont en train
d'accueillir un prisonnier
l'autorité n'a pas aimé alors les forces
de sécurité palestiniennes balance du
lacrymo sur les gens qui l'accueille
comme beaucoup à balata il vient d'une
famille affiliées au fatah le parti qui
contrôle l'autorité palestinienne
lui a choisi une autre voie il s'est
enrôlé dans le groupe qui à l'islamic un
satellite du ramasse plus radicale
la situation politique à balata ce temps
il ya un fossé entre l'autorité
palestinienne et les gens de balata
c'est une crise politique grave
on a beaucoup de gens qui sont du fatah
mais qui disent ça suffit je vais vers
la résistance le fatah maintenance et le
pacifisme
toujours le pacifisme
je ne crois pas à la résistance
pacifique alors que l'occupation
israélienne ne fait qu'augmenter les
attaques sur jérusalem cheikh jarrah à
beitar à gaza
donc j'ai choisi un autre chemin parce
que je ne veux pas tout le temps levé
les mains en l'air et ne faire que
répéter à six fils mme pacifisme
[Musique]
l'un des hommes les plus puissants du
conte jamal tirawi est conscient de
cette rupture
affilié au fatah il ne cite jamais le
nom de l'actuel leader mahmoud abbas il
se réfère uniquement à son prédécesseur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la diffusion des armes dans le camp et
l'augmentation des problèmes attise les
tensions avec les services de sécurité
palestiniens il y à toujours plus
d'armes dans les camps de réfugiés
d'autant plus que l'on a commencé à en
fabriquer
[Musique]
c'est difficile de vivre sans arme parce
que nous subissons les attaques de
l'occupation israélienne et des colons
c'est pour ça que toutes les maisons
devraient avoir des armes
il n'y a pas d'option à part la
résistance
[Musique]
ahmad affirme que l'annulation des
élections présidentielle et législatives
a compté dans son choix de rejoindre le
gros jihad islamique
comme une immense majorité de jeunes
palestiniens
il s'était inscrit sur les listes
électorales
ils auraient voté pour la première fois
au mois d'avril dernier à l' approche
des élections l'un des adversaires les
plus sérieux pour le pouvoir en place
n'est autre que le neveu de yasser
arafat
nasser al kidwa membre historique du
fatah créé une liste dissidente avant le
scrutin un crime de lèse majesté pour
mahmoud abbas qu'il exclut
définitivement du fatah au coeur de son
programme la lutte contre la corruption
nous rôder à travailler pour le
gouvernement palestinien avant de
rejoindre ce nouveau mouvement
c'est à nous d'agir
et je crois que la corruption est l'un
des plus gros problème que ce groupe
fait peser sur les palestiniens oui
et je parle de toutes les formes de
corruption
olc un
juste hier ou avant-hier on a tous été
mis au courant de nouvelles nominations
à des postes d'ambassadeurs qui ont été
horribles horriblement fait
homme
pourquoi parce que vous avez quelqu'un
qui est nommé juste parce qu'elle est la
fille de l'ambassadeur sur le départ par
exemple
à
la fin vous avez l'impression d'être
revenu au temps où les suzerains
gouverner tout
et vous n'étiez qu'un vassal
en tant que citoyen on ne s'est juste
pas partie de l'équation
il y a un groupe de gens qui sait si
ensemble et qui décide de ce qui est le
mieux pour eux
il embauche il vire il attaque et ils
utilisent les fonds publics ou les
détournent à leur guise
l'autorité palestinienne a de sérieux
problèmes
personne n'est plus réellement élu lé
tout ça se passe alors que les
palestiniens finances l'autorité
finançons le régime à travers leurs
impôts
ils payent et ils n'ont pas de
représentation
cette situation ne peut pas continuer un
des deux
c'est vrai qu'en général les
palestiniens ont des gros problèmes à
demander des comptes à l'autorité
tout simplement à cause de l'occupation
israélienne
néanmoins la majorité des palestiniens
est vraiment amis
et cette situation va exploser à la
figure de tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
en cisjordanie il existe toutefois une
bulle de liberté presque intouchable
l'université
[Musique]
ici tous les partis politiques nationaux
sont représentés et participe aux
élections étudiantes qui se tiennent
chaque année
une over l'université palestinienne de
bir zeït est très spéciale pour les
palestiniens parce qu'ici il y à des
élections c'est quelque chose dans un
pays qui n'en a pas eu depuis tant
d'années vous pouvez agir ici je peux
organiser cet événement même si cela a
été très compliqué
ce jour là sept étudiants affiliés
communiste organise avec ses camarades
une rencontre entre le frère de nizar
ben and hate et les étudiants
beaucoup sont venus en savoir plus sur
le parcours de l'opposant assassiné très
vite les questions réponses deviennent
plus politiques
pourquoi au début cette affaire a fait
beaucoup parler il ya eu un mouvement de
protestations dans la rue contre le
meurtre de nizar ben and at on ne voit
plus beaucoup ce mouvement est ce que
l'intérêt est moins grand
l'intérêt du public est de plus en plus
grands
mais les manifestations dans la rue de
moins en moins nombreuses à cause de la
pression des services de sécurité les
gens ont peur
et c'est d'ailleurs à cause de ces
pressions que nous boycottons le procès
il est devenu un symbole maintenant et
tout le monde devrait savoir ce qui lui
est arrivé
je n'avais jamais entendu son histoire
racontée directement par sa famille son
frère
l'université de bir zeït à cette liberté
d'expression ici chacun peut être celui
qu'il veut devenir
les étudiants sont farouchement attachés
à l'esprit démocratique qui est le cadre
de leurs études
beaucoup pour conscience qu'à la sortie
la réalité sera différente
demain je serai diplômé je vais me
retrouver sur le marché du travail pour
la plupart des postes auxquels je vais
postuler les enfants des dirigeants ou
les proches de l'autorité palestinienne
auront la priorité peu importe que je
sois plus qualifiés que pour cet emploi
par exemple toutes les possibilités
d'emploi dans les ministères dans les
ambassades si vous regardez bien c'est
réservé aux enfants des officiels
les enfants de la classe moyenne ou
autres on n'a pas l'opportunité donc on
se dirige vers le secteur privé où on va
travailler chez l'occupant et on devient
des employés c'est malheureusement ça la
réalité palestinienne
le cheval a félicité
lorsque l'on interroge le premier
ministre palestinien sur les
frustrations de cette jeunesse il se
veut tant patick méné mais aucune
autocritique
et les jeunes ont leurs propres rêves
leur propre demande ils veulent voir des
choses se passaient des progrès
on a un programme pour l'emploi des
jeunes mais les mesures israéliennes
font beaucoup de dégâts
je comprends leur colère on comprend ce
qu'ils veulent je dois d'ailleurs vous
dire qu'on est en train de créer une
chaîne de télévision spécialement conçu
pour parler des problèmes des jeunes ce
sera pensée pour les jeunes pour leur
inspiration afin que tous les officiels
palestiniens soit en mesure d'écouter
à ramallah c'est le premier jour du
procès des 14 officiers palestiniens
meurtrier présumé de nizar banet il se
tient devant une cour militaire
tous plaident non coupables
l'audience est publique mais dès
l'ouverture des débats
hussein est entre les mains de la
sécurité préventive
le cousin de nizar bagdad et témoin
principal est arrêté chez lui en pleine
nuit par les forces palestiniennes sa
famille qui boycottent le procès est
venu devant le tribunal
je suis là pour montrer qu'on est
présent après que les forces de
l'autorité palestinienne soit venue
arrêter chez nous le témoin principal
je suis là pour leur montrer que leur
pratique ne nous font pas peur il ne
nous terrorise pas
et c'est une banane est incarcéré neuf
jours avant d'être relâchés
les forces de sécurité l'accusent
d'avoir tiré sur une maison ce qu'il
dément avec force
pendant qu'il m'interroger et me
torturer ils ne m'ont jamais parlé de ce
sujet de cette histoire de tir le
principal sujet c'est et nizar et me
faire changer mon témoignage pour
innocenter les 14 personnes qui ont tué
nizar c'était ça le sujet au début ils
l'ont fait avec des incitations ils
m'ont proposé d'aller dans le pays de
mon choix ils m'ont proposé de l'argent
une jolie vie et tout mais ça ne marche
pas avec nous
je n'aurais jamais pensé qu'ils allaient
faire ça surtout parce que nous sommes
les témoins principaux de l'assassinât
comment il pense je n'arrive pas à
comprendre
nous sommes pris entre deux occupants
l'occupant israélien et l'occupant qui
est l'autorité de mahmoud abbas
honnêtement j'aimerais me sentir en
sécurité dans ma patrie encore plus chez
moi on ne se sent plus serein dans nos
maisons désormais
l'autorité palestinienne ne nous offre
plus de liberté et nino dignité
[Musique]
les palestiniens se sentent orphelins à
la fois de perspectives mais aussi de
dirigeants
[Musique]
de plus en plus de jeunes appels à
dissoudre cette autorité palestinienne
en bout de course qui n'offrent aucun
horizon si ce n'est celui d'une pâle
est-il toujours plus autorités
[Musique]
voilà pour ce document signé gwendoline
de bono et laurent van der stockt que
vous pouvez retrouver en replay ainsi
que tous nos reportages sur le site
france24 à la rubrique émissions et
reporter c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour
[Musique]